this morning our series earth 365 looks
at natural wonders emerging from a
submerged past but doing so at an
alarming pace because of climate change
and one place this is happening is lake
powell along the utah arizona border the
lake is a storage basin for the
southwest dwindling supply of water also
a source of hydropower and a mega
drought has drained the lake to
historically low levels
senior national and environmental
correspondent ben tracy shows us the
cost of climate change and the places
being revealed for the first time in
decades
we're going to buoy number three they
call it paul mcnabb and his dad mike are
fishing guides on utah's lake powell
they've been casting along these canyons
for decades they caught one they're
worried that the wall in front of their
favorite fishing hole will just keep
getting taller i'm looking at spots that
30 40 feet up the wall where my bait was
hitting where i was fishing just a year
ago so you're saying literally a year
ago this boat we're on right now would
have been 30 40 feet up there yep
yep it's absolutely crazy how much it's
come down
lake powell has dropped nearly 40 feet
in just one year these satellite images
show how quickly it has shriveled up
during a 22 year long mega drought as
climate change makes the west hotter and
drier this massive reservoir is now less
than 24 percent full that white bathtub
ring is where the water was before the
drought began
177 feet higher than it is now
if the lake continues to keep going down
at the rate that it is it's it's pretty
scary situation what do you predict
about the future of this business you
got i would say that we got five years
left and then your business is done yep
houseboats are already running out of
room 11 of lake powell's 12 boat ramps
are closed because they can't reach the
water if the lake keeps falling the glen
canyon dam won't be able to produce
hydro power impacting the electricity
supply for more than 5 million people in
six states
last month the assistant secretary of
the interior warned western governors of
profound concerns in operating the dam
at lower lake levels and that the
western electrical grid would experience
uncertain risk and instability well i'm
very concerned brian hill is general
manager of page utilities the arizona
town used to get 50 percent of its
electricity from the dam that's been cut
in half as lake levels have fallen
for all the southwest i think the
situation is critical so mother nature
is going to have to come to the rescue
or we're going to have to really look at
some different ways of how we use water
throughout the southwest lake powell is
considered a savings account banking
excess water and then sending it down
the colorado river to lake mead the
nation's largest reservoir
this river system supplies water for 40
million people in the west
in an unprecedented move the federal
government is holding back most of the
water that would have been sent down
river and propping up lake powell with
water from reservoirs upriver it is a
band-aid fix and everybody knows it
eric balkan runs the glen canyon
institute named for the massive canyon
that was flooded to create lake powell
back in the 1960s after the dam was
built at this moment lake powell was
born
before the dam was in place glen canyon
was considered one of the most
remarkable landscapes in the u.s people
who knew it well considered it to be as
beautiful as the grand canyon seeing
this place come back to life is just
such a special experience now as the
water recedes the lost treasures of glen
canyon are re-emerging this is just
stunning in here it's a very special
place balkan took us into what's known
as cathedral in the desert a massive
cavern of undulating rock and a
trickling waterfall so that part of the
chamber has not been seen since the
1960s when we were here last year
we were parking our boats right here and
now one of the largest natural bridges
in the country has risen out of the
water this bridge was covered by water
so what we're boating under you used to
be able to boat over he used to be able
to bow over the top of this bridge and
you think we'll be hiking under here i
think we'll be hiking under here
probably in the next few years
this is amazing it's like a dead forest
coming out of the water yeah yeah we
call them ghost forests forests once
drowned on the canyon floor are
reappearing new plants and trees are
starting to grow nearby and bulkin says
ancient footholds from indigenous people
who climbed here more than a thousand
years ago can now be seen as more and
more of these incredible one-of-a-kind
features come out of water there's no
reason they shouldn't be protected
balkan wants glen canyon to become a
national park part of a movement to
drain lake powell and fill up lake mead
since both reservoirs are at critically
low levels the purpose of the reservoir
was to store excess water and we're in a
place now where excess water is a thing
of the past the rate of change that
we're seeing now is happening way faster
than i ever thought it would
which is startling in some ways but it
also gives me a lot of hope because
we're seeing so much come back
because right now this is both a
reservoir on life support and a lost
canyon being reborn
for cbs mornings i'm ben tracy in big
water utah